liebe freundinnen und freunde gerade
jetzt wäre es wichtig dass wir uns alle
persönlich sehen und ich bin sicher
würden wir uns bei diesem parteitag
sehen
hätten wir gestern alle stehend
minutenlang dir alle gerät gedankt für
deine arbeit in den letzten jahren für
die cdu und mit markus für die union
wir werden das bei gelegenheit nachholen
denn alle 1001 wollen dir diesen dank
genau sagen
heute sehen wir uns nur digital
sie sitzen nicht hier in dieser riesigen
leeren messehalle sondern zu hause
vielleicht mit ihrer partnerin ihrem
partner ihren kindern ihrer familie auch
denen allen sage ich einen herzlichen
gruß corona lockdown mutiertes virus als
ob diese situation nicht schon
merkwürdig ist jetzt auch noch die
bilder vom kapitol in washington
amerika war doch immer für uns das land
der freiheit und der demokratie
mein vater war bergmann steiger in der
zeche anna 1 in alsdorf jeden tag 1000
meter unter der erde hitze dunkelheit
harte arbeit und er hat mir immer gesagt
wenn du unter tage bist dann ist es egal
wo dein kollege herkommt welche religion
der hat welcher herkunft wieder aussieht
entscheidend ist kannst du dich auf ihn
verlassen und alle bergleute hatten eine
erkennungsmarke die sie immer an den
nagel hängte wenn sie wieder über tage
waren heil und gesund
diese bergmanns marke trägt mein vater
der später lehrer war bis heute an
seinem schlüsselbund weil ihnen das
immer erinnert an dieses vertrauen dass
er unter tage gelernt hat und vertrauen
das ist es was uns trägt und was in
amerika zerbrochen ist
in dem ein präsident polarisiert hat
indem er zwietracht und misstrauen gesät
hat indem er systematisch gelogen hat
hat er halt und vertrauen zerstört das
ist das gift dass er in die
amerikanische seele geträufelt hat und
jetzt sehen wir wo hin das am ende führt
zerbrochene fensterscheiben und einen
büffel man mit hörnern in der herzkammer
der demokratie
viele glauben bei uns könnte das nicht
passieren
dabei hatten wir gerade erst selbst
reichskriegsflagge auf den treppen des
reichstagsgebäudes einer von uns wurde
wegen seiner haltung und seiner werte
jahrelang mit hetze bedroht und am ende
ermordet walter lübcke dem bösen wort
ist die verbrecherische tat gefolgt
liebe freundinnen und freunde walter
lübke war regierungspräsident von kassel
ein leidenschaftlicher kommunalpolitiker
und viele von ihnen sind in der
kommunalpolitik tätig erleben auch
anfeindungen oft ganz unmittelbar
aber sie machen weiter tag für tag
ehrenamtlich für das wohl unseres landes
um es klipp und klar zu sagen wir lassen
uns unser land von rechts terroristen
und von geistigen brandstiftern
kaputt machen und dann höre ich immer
wieder den satz man muss auch
polarisieren können
und ich sage nein muss man nicht
polarisieren es einfach das kann jeder
die rezepte sind bekannt das gift
schnell in der hand digital schnell zu
verbreiten
wir müssen klartext sprechen aber nicht
polarisieren
wir müssen integrieren können eine
gesellschaft zusammenhalten sehr
unterschiedliche menschen zusammenführen
das ist harte arbeit
man muss zuhören man muss unangenehmes
hören
man muss auch mit menschen zusammen
vorhanden die man vielleicht nicht so
mag
aber am ende kompromisse suchen und
lösungen die die menschen von uns
erwarten
manche unserer gegner nennen das weiter
so liebe freundinnen und freunde zu
beginn des jahrtausends wurde
deutschland beschrieben als der kranke
mann europas
als angela merkel bundeskanzlerin wurde
hat er hat uns allen rot grün mehr als
fünf millionen arbeitslose hinterlassen
angela merkel die cdu wir alle haben in
den vergangenen 16 jahren deutschland
aus dieser depression heraus geführt und
heute würde keiner mehr sagen
deutschland ist der kranke mann europas
schön und gut doch keiner wählt uns für
die verdienste der vergangenheit
deshalb muss unser blick in die zukunft
gehen
das weiter so dass wir brauchen ist die
kontinuität des erfolgs der gegenwind
ist sehr viel rauer die gegenkräfte sind
viel aggressiver geworden weiter so
erfolgreich sein heißt eben nicht alles
so
weitermachen wie bisher wir werden
vieles anders und wir werden vieles neu
machen müssen nach der pandemie aber
liebe freunde irgendwann kommt immer der
moment in dem man tacheles reden muss
und dieser moment ist jetzt es gibt
viele menschen die vor allem angela
merkel gut finden und erst danach die
cdu das ansehen der bundeskanzlerin bei
den menschen hier und international
lässt sich in einem wort zusammenfassen
vertrauen dieses vertrauen brauchen wir
jetzt als partei und dieses vertrauen
wird einem nicht geschenkt mit einem
nicht vererbt kann man auch nicht eben
mal weitergeben
dieses vertrauen muss man sich
erarbeiten und dafür reichen nicht
markige worte auch nicht schöne worte
wir drei kandidaten die wir uns heute
vorstellen wollen alle mehr
digitalisierung weniger bürokratie
ökonomie und ökologie versöhnen
artenvielfalt erhalten ein starkes
europa eine verlässliche
transatlantische allianz natürlich haben
wir viele gemeinsame ziele
wir sind ja alle in der cdu müsste
könnte sollte ist aber noch keine
politik man muss das handwerkszeug einer
politik der mitte beherrschen die
fähigkeit zur einigung das heißt das
wenn alle abstrakter von reden ökonomie
und ökologie zusammenzubringen dann
denke ich an dem kohleausstieg an
nächtliche runden im kanzleramt wo wir
verhandelt haben aber auch an den tag
danach als ich bei der
betriebsversammlung den bergleuten
erklären musste heuer kraftwerk wird
bald beschlossen und ihr geht in den
vorruhestand
während alle vom digitalen aufbruch
reden habe ich nach meinem
wahlsieg 2017 ein echtes
digitalisierungs ministerium mit der fdp
geschaffen
während alle von innerer sicherheit
reden setzen wir null toleranz gegen
rechtsbruch und kriminalität durch tag
für tag nacht für nacht wenn worte und
taten zusammenpassen dann entsteht
vertrauen vertrauen in die zukunft das
braucht es jetzt wir stehen mitten in
der größten krise unseres landes themen
die schon vor corona drängend waren sind
jetzt wieder da und dazu kommen die
wirtschaftlichen und die finanziellen
folgen der pandemie
ich denke an die vielen kleinen und
mittelständischen unternehmen an die
einzelhändler die gastronomen die
selbstständigen die banken derzeit um
ihre zukunft das eine ist das hier und
jetzt
das andere ist dass morgen
und deshalb habe ich zusammen mit jens
spahn die impulse 2021 formuliert wir
wollen dass junge leute lust haben mit
leidenschaft mitzumachen und bei dem
modernisierungs jahrzehnt das vor uns
liegt sich einbringen dass deutschland
das ich mir vorstelle ist ein
europäisches deutschland es ist führend
in der welt durch exzellenz vorbild und
menschlichkeit
wie das gelingt dazu gibt es in unserer
partei genügend genug gute ideen
die cdu muss wieder zur ideenschmiede
und zum auch der diskussion werden wir
haben das doch digital die letzten
wochen so intensiv gemacht lasst uns das
nach dem heutigen tag fortsetzen
die cdu es keine one man show das sind
sich tausende mandatsträger auf allen
ebenen 400.000 mitglieder das sind sie
zu hause vor den bildschirmen
aber wahr ist auch dass ich nicht mehr
die ganze breite der gesellschaft
in unseren reihen widerspiegelt mein
ziel ist es dass wir erste anlaufstelle
werden für alle die sagen ich will
mitmachen bei der verbesserung der welt
ich will mitmachen das land moderner zu
machen menschen alle einkommensgruppen
und bildungsabschlüsse menschen mit und
ohne einwanderungs biografie junge und
ältere frauen und männer ja wir haben
frauen in spitzenämtern die kanzlerin
die kommissionspräsidentin die
verteidigungsministerin doch die erste
reihe repräsentiert nicht die ganze
partei wir brauchen mehr frauen voll bei
uns ihre meinung ihre stärke ihre
erfahrungen ihr wissen gerade auch in
den parlamenten
eines ist doch klar wir werden nur
gewinnen wenn wir in der mitte der
gesellschaft stark bleiben wir müssen
das vertrauen der mitte in uns erhalten
und dafür treten jens spahn und ich als
team an
denn genau so ist klar das
modernisierungs jahrzehnt wird es mit
rot-rot-grün nicht geben und darum
müssen wir wirklich alles tun wirklich
alles um den wählern der mitte ein
überzeugendes angebot zu machen
wir müssen gewinnen nicht weil wir
gewinnen wollen sondern weil wir
gewinnen müssen für unser land für
unsere gesellschaft für eine gute
zukunft
die cdu und das deutschland das ich vor
augen habe braucht keinen sieg einen
vorstandsvorsitzenden sondern einen
mannschaftskapitän der führt und
zusammenführt und eine mannschaft in der
sich alle aufeinander verlassen können
wie 1000 meter unter der erde
und dann ist es auch nicht mehr wichtig
ob wir aus der mittelstands union oder
der cd a aus der jungen union oder der
senioren-union aus großen städten oder
ländlichen räumen kommen dann ist unsere
vielfalt unsere stärke und so habe ich
das als
kreisvorsitzender als landesvorsitzender
als ministerpräsident als wahlkämpfer
gemacht immer alle an bord jeder kann
groß sein jeder kann lenzen
so will ich mit euch in diese wahlen
gehen bin vielleicht nicht der mann der
perfekten inszenierung aber ich bin
armin laschet und darauf können sie sich
verlassen bevor ich hierher gefahren bin
hat mein vater mir seine erkennungsmarke
als glücksbringer mit gegeben
er hat gesagt sagt den leuten sie können
dir vertrauen
heute geht es um sehr viel
es geht um die für die demokratie
wichtigste frage wem vertrauen das
entscheiden heute sie